first up hacking Hillary hacking Hillary
karela Deville cosplayer hillary clinton
the canada america's the cannon americas
settling on because let's face it we're
not getting any younger has maintained a
steady lead at the polls where their
strategy of not talking to the press and
waiting for trump to just finally say
the n-word terror i said i said it okay
but the far right has been attacking her
over so-called health concerns and this
coughing fed at a campaign stop in
Cleveland is only gonna fan those
conspiracy theory flames take a look
anyone expected ago it's me Bernie
Sanders Oh
so comedians your convenience what's
your Hillary quipped to explain her
coughing fits Ron Funches
oh I'm sorry y'all I was smoking on that
strong unlike bill I did in here
I said Hillary's not yours rages Tiffany
well if you listen really closely you
can hear what she's really saying is
she's like I'm all you got
boy Tapani I think she's trying to say
off Bernie would have had three
strokes and driven through a farmers
market